okay
so
okay uh taina
the first thing is
your
your center has to be expanding okay
expanding and so that you generate a
relationship
not through tension but through this
expansion between
your hip corners
and your shoulder corners so you're not
doing this
okay
it's expanding expanding
okay um
so
this is this is also a marshall a
martial aspect okay
if we're if we're fighting he's gonna
hit me okay he's gonna hit me in various
places
i don't want it to weaken my structure
just as as he goes to hit me
i can move
it looks like i'm out of
alignment
but
you can push
and you're still locked you're still
locked
you're not
doing this
okay
so um
we'll just test that body you'll do
various strides all over
elbows whatever
go ahead
harder
okay
um
too often you want to do your martial
art but you're not prepared to be hit
okay
so
you
you always have this spirit of expanding
okay
uh you don't have to just aim at the
corners here you can aim at the
midsection spammers and
have like an aura of invincibility
okay let's go
[Applause]
you feel your mind
watch my face
just pulling your mind in okay there you
go
so i still i have that organization and
i do the technique boom
i don't lose that organization
the reason this is training is because
you have two stress points
one is here
and the other one is on the turn which
is why you do tie no henko okay
so
on this part right there
hold your organization on the turn
hold it on the initial press so you have
two stress points hence you have two
adaptation
possibilities
different
it's very tempting that when you're okay
you stop training but that's not the
case you're doing the same drill
but from the yin perspective so
when
he
has that first
stress point i have to offer the stress
point if i do this
then i'm not offering the stress point
and i'm no longer holding the expansion
so my body's pushing
now here
when he goes this is where a lot of you
break that expansion he goes
and you're kind of like this it's broken
hold it in the kazushi
oh
it's still walked
different
body
okay
okay uh remember last night we said
that you're not doing self-defense so
this is not a wrist grab attack
this is a training vessel
okay
but you have to add the simulated
aspects of asocial violence
and one of them is commitment
if i don't have the other one we
mentioned last night was territoriality
so if i'm
just holding his wrist i am not at all
simulating a social violence so you have
to have that spinal displacement
in your initial attack
in katatadori okay
so the other one is commitment so as
maybe i start out with territoriality
but i leave my feet here
now i don't have commitment
the way you're going to show your
commitment is that your body will move
to keep your grip
to keep your grip means your palm stays
in that same connected position the
entire time
to have not commitment is you don't move
your body and you let your grip come off
this is very incorrect
very incorrect
i push
and you'll see
that i move my body
to keep that
palm sucked to his wrist like it has a
suction cup
it's not my fingers that are doing it my
body is moving
to keep
that same exact feeling
so i'll open my hand so you'll see it's
not the grip
i move my body to keep that same feeling
do not
decommit
okay
uh move your body to keep that
connection here we go
so remember watching the technique is
part of your training do you have pure
eyes or is your ego
getting in the way
you want to be able to replicate what
you're seeing that's pure eyes okay
so i'm ukin
he goes
boom
look where i stop
i stop when he stops because i'm
training from the inside he's the arm
so i respond i first initiate the
technique and now it's him and i am in a
responsive mode
so i end up here
to keep going
do my own thing
you should have just kept going
you're doing your own thing
okay
let's go
okay uh
he goes so i have expansion remember
that's about my four corners being in
our organized state okay
he's pushing
i have
this training aspect he's working on
what i'm working on so he maintains
expansion
he provides territoriality and
commitment noted in the grip
okay uh
keep
he keeps expansion through the kazushi
that's where he he experiences the yield
so the yield right there
out of your fear you'll break it and
you'll want to walk through it you're
going to you go here and then you go
here you broke it broke expansion
you'll hear me say you've disengaged
your center activate your center so
that's what's happening you're here you
break expansion
keep expansion and allow yourself to
fall
into
the void
and then at the end
is also where you'll see someone break
expansion because they'll feel like oh
i'm done okay
so i have one stressor point here
i have the other stretching point here
and i'm supposed to maintain expansion
throughout the entire technique so if
you have a third you get he'll come and
check on you
right here you're going to push
you can push both hands both hands over
here
and nothing changes
me me
when i go
i'm very relaxed and comes in and then i
get ready for him can you see that
expansion boom here he comes nothing
changes in my body nothing at all okay
you're still doing the same thing
oh still expansion still expansion
all right let's go
okay so continuing on what you're
working on in chinese
you're also working on the
the combative geometry
to use jiu jitsu okay so
somewhere you're going to reconcile
an attack
with yin
it'll almost always be on a circle
then as you reconcile the yin within
you'll enter
then you'll ten con okay
uh that'll always happen so let's say
we're fighting he comes in that right
there that what i did right here that's
a yin reconciliation
he's going to keep entering right
there's my uh
enter right here he's going to re-engage
and that's yours
somewhere some variation of that will
come up the fight starts to
rotate in this
moving spiral across the map okay
so
the first part is the yin reconciliation
as he
is doing the territoriality i'm going to
shift my weight
ever so slightly
i'm not going to turn
with double weighted feet
whoa that was it
that also establishes the ground vector
so he's pushing and this foot's
irrelevant now to his territoriality
okay
so it starts to lead into the internal
training
so pull single pivot point
start the rotation
enter into the empty space
and then
so not turn
yield first establish the single pivot
point turn enter on the turn
pen punch
yield
turn
enter on the turn
yield
single pivot point again
the tank on foot goes straight back
it does not
draw a circle
across the mouth
single pivot point
single pivot point straight back
straight back
[Music]
okay so let's go back
let's uh micro drill the first yield and
understand what's going on
okay
you will you want to always establish a
ground path
and when you rotate you always have a
single pivot point you never double
pivot never double pivot
so i know on the on the edema on the
entrain it's gonna be on a turn so i'm
gonna have to pivot on that okay so i
want a single pivot point
and i want to use my internal aspects
and so i always want a ground vector
okay
so we're just micro drilling that i also
know i want a yin yield that's the yin
yield
so if i
he's pushing
i'm not going anywhere because i can
establish a ground vector anywhere i am
okay
i'm yielding out of strategic reasons
so i'm on the back foot
i have no weight on the front foot
but i have the ground vector
let him move me onto the back foot
ground vector
four corner organization
expanding center
different
you see i'm turning
oh
he pushes
i move it to the back foot
if you want you can test he's pushing it
doesn't matter whatever i'm doing with
that back foot
does not matter
so
okay
let's get that going micro drill help
okay your art is made up of energetic
things but it is also made up of
mechanical things okay
so
his first
stress
stressor
i have expansion four corner
organization
and i established a ground vector
now mechanically you want to also
understand angle cancellation
so when you do this you never want his
hand to go down
angle cancellation is
best achieved through two zones through
dimensions so in this case it's going to
be uh width and height
so i don't want to just go down that
would be height only
i want width and height
tilt is what we use most of the time
in our aikido okay so we don't want to
use just height
height we don't do it like this okay
always
height and width there's the tilt
it always leads to our kozushi
okay
so this elbow as i do the yin
reconciliation following the single
ground vector that elbow goes in
and weight is on it
then i enter
on the turn
so never like this
always in and wait on it and get on okay
next mechanical
reconciliation
i don't want to enter so that i'm on the
bottom side of the circle because i'm
going to have to pull this thing
into position
of course if i have good expansion you
can do it
but partially not as sound
because you're not in what is called the
zona sanctuary you want to be where he
can hit you and that is generally behind
the shoulder okay minimum
back good other shoulder could
off to the side not good
so you want to move into the zone
sanctuary
and that's going to require you
to be on the
top side of the circle and you will not
pull
on the grip because you're on the other
side of the grip
boom
get to the top side of the circle
establish a single pivot point
and now you don't pull that bridge
i'm on the other side of the circle
other side of the circle
different
i'm on the bottom side of the circle
you want to get
to the top side of the circle
you should not feel their fingers
anymore you reconcile the grip
so the question i
if you've studied with me for a while
you know we used to talk about
uh
extension
and as i watched
you try to learn uh i started
saying
not tension extension or extension is
not tension
okay because
when you try to
hold him at bay
you just
think this is extension but you're
flexing everything okay
and that is not
it
okay that's that is a fear response
and
that is not a yin yielding
and there's no way you can get the
internal aspects through that tension
okay it's also not martial
it's very very hard to move quickly
and responsibly
when i am very tense
okay so maybe at first when you're
trying our beginner coq drills you're
like this do you see
and
it'll never translate into any time we
have to move past this okay
and if we're going more live you will
not be able to function at all it just
doesn't function so i'm definitely not a
fan of
starting your kimonos uh
in these
these positions do you see how much
tension i'm holding in my body right
uh so he goes
[Music]
it is very very stiff
you see
[Music]
this is
not
what i want i don't want to live life
in a state of tension okay
you're gonna do the same things
you go ahead you push
push
you're gonna do the same
things
push hard
get a good base
use your two hands
push push
push push hard into me push hard into me
push hard into me there you go here we
go
push
same thing
very relaxed
push
push hard
very relaxed
it can be done
but it's not as easy
okay
we understand tension
because
it's from our ego tripartite
i will out muscle you i will outpower
you do you see
we understand that our ego understands
that
i understand that
we don't understand this other thing
what the art is actually trying to teach
you
okay so it's always very
it's always very interesting perplexing
amazing
flabbergasting that
we're told in the art
relax
but everybody is very stiff very very
stiff
uh especially when you contrast it with
other arts
that don't make such claims about
relaxing
you see
uh bjj way more those people are way
more relaxed than these other aikido
people
um
boxers same thing very relaxed as
they're moving
never
start the fight like that you see
or comparatively uh
you have a systema will put most of
aikido people to shame when it comes to
relaxing okay
so it's very very
perplexing so today
is a noticeable shift in
nomenclature because i'm watching as i'm
instructing
that
extension
is not quite it either tension's not it
but extension is not it either
primarily because it's so easy to
confuse extension with tension
but also because extension
is a
structural integrity
along a single vector and that's not it
either that's that's what lends itself
to tension
expansion is on all vectors all vectors
do you see
uh not just the one in front of you all
vectors are doing it okay
um
also that's more in line with what's
actually happening to you okay
so
uh if we go to ancient body wisdom a old
old body wisdom which
uh japanese martial arts
um have a historical connection with
okay it's
not they're not going to invent a
japanese martial art that is not
grounded in this more ancient
um
asian body wisdom
okay um
it's not that strange a concept
and i think we'd be foolish to believe
otherwise but
our americanist
scientistic
understanding of our body
is not in alignment with this ancient
wisdom but our intuitive common sense
experience of our body should still keep
this making sense all right
and it is this
um
any emotion that you have any kind of
thought any anything in your mind
happens and manifest in use in your in
yourself physically okay so the easy one
for example
is
um when you are afraid and or tense
let's say you have a lot of stress at
work okay
you have a lot of stress at work we all
think that stress is just a mental thing
right
and um
we
look deeper and you'll see that
somebody will come and rub your
shoulders and go whoa
that you got a knot there like if it was
purely ideational
why is it showing up in a physical
muscle knot as we would call it you see
because
there is a connection between my
ideational self and my physical self it
shows up in my body
however
you ever go to the doctor
let's say you have an abdominal issue of
some kind some kind of digestive problem
all right
and the doctor will ask you about your
life and they go oh you have stress and
you always feel ashamed a little
embarrassed or even like the doctors not
believing you that you have some
physical thing right
uh they might go oh you it's a stress
response no i'm not making this up
i really could feel something yes
the ancient body wisdom would go of
course all right
in this ancient body wisdom
they categorize certain feelings with
certain parts of your body
desires
dissatisfaction
which perceives desire
these two things are located
in the lower pelvic region
fear
is located
in the naval region all right
so
when you go to do
[Music]
your martial art
because the way budo trains you through
fear
through a reconciliation of the ego
tripartite by reconciling
fear
pride and ignorance
things like desire
to not lose to fail to stay safe and
fear to not get injured
is all in the midsection
so you always
collapse the midsection
before you even know it
okay
so he comes in
we're doing our drill and i know that i
have to
go here you see
no i have a desire since i said to go
there i have a desire and i desire not
to do this
and already that thing has weakened oh
oh you don't realize it but you already
weakened it okay
so
i i have to be desireless so i can get
here
i don't have any fear because i don't
have a
dichotomy between between him and i
so it's not
nage versus uke that's not what's going
on i'm already in an expanded state and
you'll just land there
without that tension
or
the opposite
which is the need for tension let's say
as you're experiencing it subjectively
that wasn't it either
okay
so expansion expansion expansion
expansion expansion
non-contestation means unification
between
uke and nage means no difference between
and nadia
no difference between moving and not
moving either once i get all those
things around i can truly have expansion
and therefore have relaxed movement
with the structural integrity of
expansion versus a structural integrity
only through tension
okay do you understand
all right
um
so i can't do i can't truly do the art
until i get to this
what we moderns would call
emotional
reconciliation or this ideational
reconciliation but which the pre-moderns
would say dude your body mind is
intimately connected you're going to
have ideas that manifest in the body you
can move the body to manifest different
ideas in your mind it goes both ways
okay
that is what makes training in a martial
art a viable
system of
trans substantiation
which is what we actually do versus
transformation we're going to actually
change the very substance